yesterday was flat out embarrassing you
ever go to the dentist vic you have to
have your teeth pulled out
you know it's pretty much like that they
can catch the ball or they can get
replaced by those that will catch it
have a freaking
sense of urgency know where we're at
have some pride into who we're playing
for and why we do this i mean
honestly like could i have done any
better of course i could have done that
we take it off you know don't nobody
like losing
that was one of the worst football games
i've ever been a part of
in my 30 years in the national football
league i don't think there's a question
your ex derrick henry or anybody else
like you i'm saying like i'm a running
back
i know wear it down it's gotten so
really jacked up of how
the catch roll is somebody that's
sitting back watching this probably
hadn't thrown a football in his life
is to call it would you attribute that
to anything in particular
uh sucky you could find a smart aleck
bus driver in kansas city who made some
snide comments
when we got on the bus maybe that's why
we drove around the stadiums to
tick him off you know this is ridiculous
next question
[Music]
well i could just watch that for 20
minutes instead of uh that was a good
one
that's better than that's better than
anything we say it says roll
just roll coaches and players upset at
press conferences
uh although you would eventually run out
of content but that was enough there to
whet our appetite as to what we have
coming now it is festive it's december
23
the fake holiday from the fake tv show
that has endured unlike anything from
the nine seasons of seinfeld
the frank costanza invented day
as a rebellion against christmas and all
of the various
uh commercial aspects of it i don't know
what i don't know what it was that made
him upset about christmas i think it was
something about a doll he was trying to
get for george or something like that i
can't remember anymore either
yes but anyway every wednesday we air
grievances especially during the season
and chris we have allotted some extra
time today since it is festivus and i
will give you
the honors both with the feats of
strength that'll come later
and for now the airing of grievances all
right well i i think the
uh mine's easy okay i know you got some
like ready to go but this is just purely
like a football one that's bothering me
here down the stretch and it's something
that like
pete dem a little a little lighter
lightest right
texted about a little on our text chain
the other day which is
the seven teams in the playoffs i really
like it okay
it's cool it has added another little
element to this whole thing
but i'll tell you what i really don't
like one of the unintended quant
consequences at least they're not
unintended but maybe something we didn't
talk about or realize
how much flair it adds to the end of the
season conversation
is the fact that we don't have a number
two home
seed a number two seed with the first
round bye
getting that home playoff game race that
was another race that was fun to watch
down the stretch i mean again let's not
forget does kansas city get to the super
bowl last year
if they don't win on week 17 and the and
the patriots lose to the dolphins i
don't know
you know that chance that they got that
number two seed and
skipped the wild card game and got their
time to rest that certainly set them up
and what i just feel like this year it
would be an unbelievable year
for for the race for the number two seed
right now i mean you look at it
really and the nfc okay yeah it's it's
a pretty good race the afc the whole the
whole damn conference could fight for
the number two seed that's in the
playoffs right now
i mean everybody would be involved in
that conversation i'm worried we're
gonna get to week 17
and have no meaningful football games
that that's what i'm really worried
about that maybe we have
won or something like that but i think
there's a good chance we get there and
especially a year with no fans where
everybody's going to be like yep there's
really nothing to play for it's
good it's good i'm glad we got another
you know 17th week but nobody's playing
for anything and and
if we had that number two seed with the
first round bye
there would be definitely something to
play for and we'd see better football
week 17. so that's something that's uh
annoying me a little bit and that's a
good point our focus is the one seat in
each conference and
which wild card teams are going to get
in in each division
some or each conference excuse me
somebody's going to be omitted and
there's
there's only so many chairs and there's
one but
too many of quality chairs in each
conference but
once we get past the one seed between
the one seed and the seventh seed
right to me it's just kind of this vague
golf of i don't care we'll figure that
out later it doesn't matter especially
this year
where home field advantage doesn't
matter who cares who's going to be two
three
four five six what matters is who's
gonna be one and who's gonna be
seven and everything else in between
it's not worth the time to give yourself
a headache figuring it all out because
there's no significant benefit for it
no you know we could sit here look at
the dolph i mean the colts they're 10
and four
we could be talking about hey the colts
are still you know
capable of getting the number two seed
and getting a first round buy at this
in the number 16 right now that would
add a lot of intrigue and things it's
just one of the things i think was a
little bit of an unintended consequence
and maybe that's where now the nfl will
be able to play
let's go to eight team playoff and go
back to the first
top two teams get the buy and now we
still have the same wild card format
that we'll have this year and that seems
eventually where it's gonna go as you
predicted a long time ago
yeah but i think when they go to eight
teams per conference no one gets a bye
we'd have to sit down and think about
how to do this where you add playoff
teams
and also preserve buys it may get more
complicated that way you may ultimately
need more teams
in the nfl to have a playoff field that
would be expanded and that would
preserve those buys but i think that's a
great point and i think we're realizing
that as we look ahead
to week 17 we the the top seed races are
probably going to be resolved yeah and
there may just be one or two if we're
lucky pittsburgh cleveland right now is
looking like it might be the only game
that yeah maybe
right but they're both getting in it's
not like there's going to be a playoff
elimination game it's just do you win
the division
or are you a wild card and this year it
doesn't matter if the loser is out
right if there's a chan and between the
browns ravens and colts one of those
teams could possibly miss the playoffs
with an 11-5 record which would only be
the second time that's happened
since they expand the playoffs to 12
teams in 1990
and you wouldn't think that the first
year they go to 14 an eleven and five
team
doesn't make it but it could happen um
and and
i i guess in theory if the steelers
would win this weekend
and the browns would lose next weekend
there's a way that they potentially
get out and then the steelers could
deliver the knockout blow for the browns
but that could be the thing that opens
the door for the ravens i don't know if
you're the steelers i mean you'd rather
play the browns and the ravens in the
postseason but anyway
it's still all kind of vague and it's
not really crystallized
and i don't know how much is even going
to be there after this week
there may be a chance that all 16 games
in week 17 we look at and say
they really don't decide anything this
year and maybe that's just
randomness maybe next year it'll be
different but uh you're right
to get back to your point not having
that buy that second buy
really takes away one of the things that
we would be focused on and it would be
fascinating in both conferences all
right
first one for me and and this was one
that that just popped up last night with
the news that josh gordon will not be
joining the seahawks after all because
he failed to comply with one of the
terms of his plan for re-entry to the
nfl
as it relates to the use of substances
that aren't peds
remember this is a substance abuse
policy that
focuses only on street drugs marijuana
and related substances
that players aren't allowed to use in
their
free time even though they have up to
seven months of free time depending upon
whether or not they're going to be
involved in the off season program
and the problem i've had with this chris
and this goes back to when i practiced
law there was always a fine line as to
how far
an employer could go or should go
when policing the private life of an
employee
and to me this is so far over the line
and the problem is
because such a prominent employer like
the nfl does it
other people think every employer does
it other people think
it's okay because the nfl does it i made
an observation about it last night that
it's a shame the nfl still feels
compelled to police the private lives of
players when it comes to substances that
have nothing to do
with their actual or expected work
performance and so many of the responses
on twitter where everybody does it
everybody does it no they don't
so they don't know they don't insane no
they don't right you're right but
but people become conditioned because
the nfl is trampling frankly in all due
respect on the private
lives of these individuals you have
other people out there if they're
working for an employer that decides to
do the same damn thing maybe the manager
gets inspired by what the nfl is doing
then hey it's fine with us wall street
would have to go
by the one of the best biggest
institutions in our country would have
to go
by the wayside if they had the rules you
guys can't pay
our money anymore are you kidding me all
these things we found in your systems
so yes all right go ahead so anyway i
just i
i thought we had gotten there with and
and i'm going to expand my
my grievance a little bit to cover the
nfl pa because
when they revise the latest cba one of
the benefits for the players is there
would be no
future suspensions under the substance
abuse policy now you'd have to pay some
money you could get fined but you're
never going to be prevented from playing
just for testing positive
if you deliberately fail to comply with
your treatment plan then they can
suspend you but it's not like it used to
be
the only problem is you had guys out
there who were kind of floating around
who had been suspended under the old
rules indefinitely alton smith
and randy gregory and josh gordon and
martavius bryant
they didn't make any allowance for these
guys to get back in so they had to go
through the old path some of them got
back in gordon's not getting back in
it's just a damn shame
because it has nothing to do with his
job performance this is big brother
father knows best the war on drugs from
40 years ago
it's all outdated and i just think the
nfl is out of line
and the nfl is hurting itself in keeping
talented football players off the field
yeah i got a problem with it
yeah well i hear that i do think you're
right i mean i think they're
they're keeping a lot of the you know
talented football players who can make
the league better for
you know again some of these some of
these things have been
serious through the years with players
and all that but for the most part
no like you're saying most businesses
wouldn't even blink an eye on what some
guys have been suspended for in the nfl
or would never even know that their
their their employee employer employee
or anybody does anything like that
uh i do think that sometimes it crosses
the line
a little bit here there's no doubt and
hey i want josh gordon
to be healthy and everything to be good
in his life and everything go the right
direction
um which it seems like it is i just hope
it's
yeah not some trivial little part of
this
that's like oh he missed a he missed one
session with his therapist that we
thought was necessary for him to go see
you know once a week and now that's why
he didn't like
you know fulfill the conditions of the
reinstatement if it's something like
that that would really piss me off sorry
london
oh and maybe thank you and maybe he
would be better off if he had the
structure of a football team if he had
employment if he had gainful employment
and
and people could be around him and they
could be a positive influence
i'm amazed he doesn't have more issues
when he's left to his own devices and
cast away
from the seahawks or any other team all
right let's uh let's see what else she
got yeah no no
that was mine one i know you got two
though so i want to hear this section uh
yeah well i got i actually got i
i came up with another one today it may
have to wait for another time though
i i have uh two things related to
the looming search for coaches one
is a corollary to what we always hear
during college games
about how oh we're going to see that guy
on sunday next year oh we're going to
see that guy on sunday we've talked
about that in the past
it's ridiculous all these guys that were
supposed to see on sunday there'd be
64 teams in the nfl if all those guys
made
it to sunday they don't but i i don't
know why it happens i don't get it i
but it happens the same dynamic plays
out as we get closer and closer to
filling these coaching jobs specifically
the coaching jobs
and i'm not going to name names here
because i don't want to imply that i
believe the person isn't suited to be a
head coach but my god every game you
watch
it seems like one of the assistant
coaches involved in the game
is a hot coaching candidate who will
have a job next year folks there's only
so many of these jobs to go around
no they won't have a job next year
chances are they won't because there's
only
three openings right now and we don't
know how many more they're going to be
maybe there'll be two more maybe
there'll be five
there's a hell of a lot more than five
guys whose names i've heard over the
past five weeks
as guys who are definitely going to be
head coaches next year chris and i don't
know whether people in the media are
doing that just
to buddy up to people it promotes access
hey i said good things about you
you know and it may be part of that that
game
that plenty of people in our business
play but
it just bugs me because i could rattle
off a list
of 15 guys who i've been told are going
to be head coaches next year well
a lot of guys are going to have to get
fired if all those guys are going to be
coaches next year no no
it is crazy mike and like i'll just say
my two cents on that
these like you know conversations or
these you know public storms of this
guy's going to be the head coaches
it's all started by the coaches so that
that's where i like we we want to blame
the media and sometimes and guys like
you and me and we're talking about no
the coaches are the ones that start
these little like media pushes for
themselves it's part of the the game
outside the game here
and that's really where i think it
happens mike because you know
one let's just say you're an offensive
coordinator he starts to
you know get his name out there tells
his agent hey i want to get my name
involved in this he calls the right
people to do that
the local writer that's following the
team now he's been informed
and he puts it out there now the tv crew
that's going to follow the game that
week
they read the local news right and oh
hey you know
johnny from this newspaper wrote about
hey the offensive coordinators
he might be a head coach and then it
becomes a talking point you're right but
it's really to me the root of it
starts with the coaches selling
themselves
to the media and their friends to get
their name out there and start it that
way which
you know i don't know if a lot of people
really realize that's how it starts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports